foreign
welcome back to our Channel today we
have an exciting topic to discuss we are
going to explore the various ways you
can make money using charge repeating an
AI power tool that can help you generate
passive income if you are ready to start
breaking in the cash without breaking a
sweat then keep watching but before we
begin if you love watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel like the
tutorial and hit the Bell icon to now
miss an update and now introducing the
number one ranked Ai and ml course the
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning that is in partnership with
Purdue University and IBM this program
offers comprehensive education in high
demand skills like machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision and more
and it Master tools such as python
tensorflow Keras and chat GPT and gain
practical experience through real world
projects with an industry recognized
certification networking opportunities
and career support this program is
designed to boost your career in the AI
and ml industry don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity to learn from Top
tile institutions and Excel in this
field enroll today moving on if you are
looking for ways to generate passive
income without putting in too much
effort thanks to the advancement in
artificial intelligence and chat boards
it's now possible to earn money using
these Technologies in this video we'll
explore some of the effective ways to
generate passive income with chatubity
check is known for being the world's
smartest generative Ai and is changing
the game when it comes to making money
online with this revolutionary free tool
you can earn with little skill and no
Capital required there is an exciting
New Era of artificial intelligence and
now is the perfect time to get involved
and take advantage of this opportunity
people are using chargepatty for YouTube
blogging freelancing and for many other
ways to make money so let's dive in and
discover how to make money using chat
Jeopardy and generate various passive
incomes there are variety of ways that
you can make money using share Jeopardy
we'll discuss few of them in this video
and we'll start with first we'll see the
list of all the ideas from which you can
make money the first is get business
ideas from chat Jeopardy second is
freelancing third is build a software
fourth is boost your affiliate marketing
with chat Jeopardy's email expertise
fifth is leverage igbt for blogging
success the next is unlock the potential
of charge Deputy for affiliate marketing
and then we have utilized chat jbd for
ebook writing and and self-publishing
this is the main thing what people are
doing to make money using charity and
then when you have utilized charity to
enhance your YouTube channel and then we
have writing lyrics for music so
starting them one by one we'll start
with get business ideas from church
Equity by getting to know your interest
talent and obstacles chat Jeopardy can
generate tailored business Concepts that
align with your expectations let's Dive
Right In and ask Chad Jeopardy for some
business ideas for a computer science
engineer who has experience in digital
marketing and sales chat repeating and
ask him that I am a
computer science graduate the computer
science engineer
with experience in sales and marketing
and what side Hustle
should I start
generate
around thousand dollars to generate
thousand dollars
income that would be per day
and that would be with minimum
investment amount
right and this is
okay with minimum investment
and I can also tell him how many hours I
can dedicate so I can dedicate it
to 10 hours
to this side Hustle
press enter
so you could see that chat Jeopardy
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expense and sales and
marketing there's several side levels
two generate thousand dollars income per
day
and he has stated the first one is
e-commerce then affiliate marketing
digital products you can create and sell
digital products such as ebooks okay
freelancing social media management and
YouTube channel you can start your
YouTube channel
so these are the ideas that you can get
from chat Jeopardy and but these ideas
tailored to user skills and interests
that I have put in now it's time to take
these ideas and discuss them further
with chat Jeopardy to conceptualize a
plan so consider important factors like
alternatively you can begin by stating
generate a new business idea poor
digital products you can write that and
he will guide you how you can start it
or you could just write
can you elaborate
the business
idea
of
digital
products
I am on
to start the site
with this
and then you press enter
and you can see that it has started
the process for the business idea
certainly starting a side as well
centered around digital products can be
lucrative and fulfing Venture identify
your expertise
it manure areas of knowledge skills and
passion and then he has stated choose a
product format create valuable content
set up an online platform Market your
products build an audience optimize for
conversions provide excellent customer
support so these are the parts he has
stated and moreover you can
elaborate those parts also you can just
ask chat Deputy so how can I identify my
expertise and he will guide you with
that so you can go deep down and explore
any business idea so this was the first
method through which you can generate
income from chair GPD and moving on the
next would be freelancing so take your
freelancing game to the next level with
chair Jeopardy this date of the art AI
tool is enabling professionals to earn
extra income and produce top quality
content that pose clients companies are
even offering incentives for those who
utilize this technology to create
polished well researched work so here
are some freelance services that you can
offer using chat GPT
starting with you can write blog or
website content using chatgpt for others
you can translate any language with
chatgpt you can craft compelling
headlines and calls to action with chat
GPT and moreover you can do create
social media content for posts or
marketing for other people or any
advertising agency you can write
captivating short stories using chat
deputy and you can conduct hashtag
research using chatributing that is you
can find what is trending and offer your
services to other people and gain money
so these are the ways in which you could
freelance and have some money in your
pockets so you could just write a
command that would be write a blog post
and
you could write on any topic that would
be write a blog post on
U.S economy
so you could use this AI tool as your
means like what the what your client
required you can use for that and write
the perfect without plagiarism content
that would be blog post and you can
translate any language with chai triputi
you can write
competitive headlines and calls and you
can also write social media content that
would be you can use SEO research for
that and you can write short stories
also see that he has given you the blog
post on the topic U.S economy the
navigating uh the title is navigating
the current state of the U.S economy
Trends and insights and you can see that
it has given you six points and if you
want more you can just ask him to
elaborate
elaborate this
and I've found this blog post
in 800 words
so the thing you just have to do is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
too in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat jpd
so now it will write the blog post that
would be in 800 words
so
it's good and moving on
what we'll do let's check out monopod
Learners what he has to say about our
courses we need to keep updating your
skills on a regular basis no matter what
level you're at I recently completed the
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
in partnership with Purdue University
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning now
coming back so the third passive income
you could make using charge up it is
building a software imagine this
scenario you have an issue with your
online business
and you realize that many other people
are facing the same problem well here's
where chair deputy comes to the rescue
you can utilize chair Jeopardy to create
software using report provided by the AI
and then you can sell these software
tools to make money it's as simple as
that by leveraging chat Jeopardy's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a ready Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also impose others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you are a problem solver and have a
knack of four coding why not use charge
ability to create software tools that
can make a real happy start by
identifying common pain points that also
you can ask from chat Jeopardy you can
just ask the chat jpt I want to create a
software to help others during or in
online processes in online e-commerce so
he'll give you suggestions and then you
can proceed with those suggestions and
create a software and then you can sell
it or you can use for your own use
so now embrace the power chat jpt tap
into its coding expertise and unlock the
potential to create and sell software
tools so your journey to financial
success starts right here and moving on
we'll move to the next income source
that we can gain from charging so you
can boost your affiliate marketing with
chat Jeopardy's email expertise so do
you know that charity processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatbot can drop
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services chat Jeopardy
has caught you powered that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat GPT and ask
him that
email marketer
and need to
sell my CRM software
so write
an email
only
so I can attract
customer
and make them bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of
child supporting let's discuss how you
can Kickstart your email affiliate
marketing campaign the first step is to
choose an affiliate program that aligns
with your Niche whether it's Amazon's
Spotify Shopify convertkit or any other
program make sure it suits your target
audience next it's time to build an
email list of potential customers who
are generally interested in your
promoted products or Services you can
use lead magnets or employ other
effective methods to encourage email
signups you could see that he has
written the email that is I hope this
email finds you well as an email
marketed person okay this is for me and
you could start from here at your
company we have developed a powerful CRM
solution reload specifically for email
marketers like yourself our software
combines Advanced features user friendly
okay here is written for uh email
marketers only as targeted audience that
is email marketer no issue you can ask
him to change that and like you can
craft compelling emails with chair
Jeopardy and this is where chat Jeopardy
truly shines with its assistance you can
create highly engaging emails that not
only inform users about the benefits of
the products but also Inspire them to
click on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chat about
biosite imagine having a chatbot by your
side helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compelling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click-through rates
so this is how chat Jeopardy can help
you in email marketing now the next
method is leverage child Jeopardy for
blogging success in the realm of
blogging charge repeating offers an
array of advantages that can elevate
your content creation Journey so the
first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome writer's block
chat GPT assist bloggers by generating
ideas crafting outlines anyone providing
complete routes for blog posts say
goodbye to our spend on Research with
charge Deputy you can access relevant
information statistics and facts and
mere seconds elevate your blogging game
and Unleash Your Potential with this an
invaluable source
and then you can add it and proofread
using charge update if you have written
any content and get any content written
you could just write what we have
already written that was write a blog
post on U.S economic that we have seen
in freelancing uh side Hustle but here
you can write and not only write but
also if you have added some points with
your research you can proofread and edit
by using chargpt that is for bloggery
proves to be a valuable asset by
offering assistance in editing
proofreading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat Jeopardy Define your writing and
ensure a blog post shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for a blogging journey is keyword
research and SEO optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chargipti becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structuring your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat GPS SEO expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be gaming related
SEO keywords
score and the topic could be online
shopping
and press enter so here are some related
SEO keywords for online shopping you
could see all these you would mention
these on your backlinks if you have
website or you could add into your blog
posts hashtags which can gain you rank
when searched so moving back the next
was audience engagement so engaging your
audience is key to building a thriving
blow charity can assist you in
connecting with the readers on a deeper
level it towards conversation status
answer common questions and addresses
concerns from your Audience by
leveraging Charity's capabilities you
can post on meaningful interactions
cultivated low and following and force
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of charge Deputy
bloggers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate their target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of charge deputy and embark on
an exciting blog Journey it will leave a
lasting impact so moving on we'll now
see another side herself that is unlock
the potential of charge every for
affiliate marketing and you could do
easily affiliate marketing if you have
this blogging thing
so affiliate marketing opens up a world
of earning possibilities and shared GPT
can your trusted Ally on this rewarding
Journey users of chargeupt can leverage
its capabilities to generate income
through affiliate marketing this
powerful tool provides a seamless Avenue
for promoting Goods services and Brands
all while learning a commission based on
resulting sales embarking on an
affiliate marketing Venture requires
thoughtful planning as a blogger or
content creator you must carefully
select the medium through which you will
build your audience whether it's through
captivating articles engaging audio
content or compelling videos you have
the freedom to choose the format that
aligns with the strengths and resonates
with your target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chair Deputy steps into support
your affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with by collaborating
with chai Jeopardy you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with with your audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy chargibility becomes an
invaluable resource it helps you to
draft engaging articles record
compelling audio content or script
captivating videos that highlight the
benefits and value of the products or
services that you are promoting so
remember affiliate marketing is a
process that requires dedication and
perseverance through consistent effort
and the support of charge GPT you can
unlock the potential of earning
substantial income by promoting products
and services that resonate with your
audience and this was for the affiliate
marketing and the next big thing is
utilize chair Jeopardy for ebook writing
and self-publishing so are you a
passionate writer seeking fresh and
innovative ideas look no further charge
everybody revolutionizes your writing
experience in a recent report that
revealed that AI written ebooks have
experienced a remarkable search on
Amazon so you could just won't charge
deputy and ask him
I want to write a self
help book
add to
Black version free
okay I think yeah no spelling is correct
and it's
should have
resonating
chapters there's no needing
chapters
so
provide me
with a list of checkers
as you can see that
it will Define you
and you can also ask the title for the
book and it will give you the perfect
title and you can see the chapters that
is introducing setting the stage for
personal growth discovering your
authentic self cultivating a positive
mindset and after that you can ask
charity to elaborate these topics that
would be in some words in some pages and
you can use the same content to write a
book and you can also ask the title from
the chat jpd
as you create a companion the
possibilities are boundless you don't
need to possess the skills of literary
genius to make an impact in the e-book
Market Kindle Direct publishing offers
seamless platform to Showcase your book
and make it easily accessible to
enthusiastic readers while leveraging
charge Deputy to assist in writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income
using chair GPD moving on we have next
passive income that is utilized chargpt
to enhance your YouTube channel
so charge everybody is an invaluable
tool that can assist you in generating
captivating video ideas you can ask him
the video ideas also and this is the
creative block charge if you can even
cool the extra mile by creating a script
for YouTube videos
so let's tap into the creative progress
and we'll ask chair jpt I want to create
a YouTube video
on topic
uh GDP
that is close domestic product and
I need your help
writing the script for that
so you could see that chair GPD has
started its work so it's showing welcome
back to our channel in today's video
we'll be diving into the fascinating
world of Tube8 GDP what exactly is GDP
and why is it such an important measure
of a country's economy so you can see
that it has created the script for your
YouTube video and it is also telling you
the scenes
so this is how you could leverage your
Japanese capabilities and that can give
you YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with chat Deputy today and witness your
channel Thrive so moving on the next we
have is writing lyrics for music so when
it comes to music the words we use in
songs are super important they have the
power to make us feel all kinds of
emotions and connect with people and now
there's a cool tool called chargabity
that can help you write awesome song
lyrics with Charity you can take your
ideas and turn them into beautiful words
that touch people's heart it's like
having a virtual writing buddy that help
you come up with catchy lines and cool
Rhymes you can play around with
different ways to express yourself and
make your lyrics stand out so you can
chat GPT to write lyrics for you and
that's all for today's video If you find
this information helpful don't forget to
hit the like button and subscribe to our
channel for more exciting content thank
you for watching and we'll see you in
the next video Stay inspired and keep
thriving
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign